the NSA has trillions of telephone calls
and emails in their databases that
they've collected over the last several
years
why shouldn't you mr. Greenwald be
charged with a crime since breaking the
story of NSA surveillance abuses Glenn
Greenwald has championed the cause of
whistleblowers and skooled establishment
journalists in the meaning of the First
Amendment for his efforts government
officials have publicly called for
Greenwald's arrest he won the Pulitzer
Prize for public service and today he's
the subject of citizen for an Academy
Award nominated documentary about Edward
Snowden
so I don't know anything about you okay
my name is Edward Snowden I go by ahead
Edward Joseph Snowden's the full name
the winner of Reason Foundation's 2014
lani Friedlander prize not only has
broken the biggest news story in a
generation he's following it up by
co-founding the intercept a magazine
that aims to shake up American
journalism reason TV caught up with
Greenwald in Montreal where he was
delivering a lecture at McGill
University about terrorism and
government surveillance
[Music]
glenn greenwald it is a pleasure to talk
to you great talk to you and thank you
so much to to reason for this award to
i'm really honored to receive it so
let's let's get right into it i loved
your book no place to hide it reads in
many ways like an all the president's
men for the 21st century with you and
Laura Poitras playing the role of
Woodward and Bernstein and where they
differ sort of is what really interests
me even though it's sort of a timeless
tale right at the end of all the
president's men you have a president who
resigns you have people who go to jail
you have some measure of accountability
that's the end game and I don't know if
we're quite at the endgame here with
this scenario but do you see that ever
happening do you see a some measure of
accountability or today have things
changed to such a degree where the
government just acts with impunity I do
you know I mean even in in Watergate
that took a relatively long time from
the original disclosures to the point
where Washington the political class
took it seriously to the point where
there was accountability and in fact if
you look at the first year and a half or
two years of Watergate reporting
overwhelmingly polling broke down along
partisan lines where Republicans were
rather dismissive of the seriousness of
what was being reported and Democrats
were sort of trying to exploit it for
political gain and it was only once a
kind of reached a tipping point and some
prominent Republicans came out and said
this is really wrong and then the battle
over the the tapes did it all sort of
unfold the way we now remember it but it
took a good while the nature of
politically powerful people is that they
have a lot of defenses and a lot of
strength by definition and and you don't
deflate them or bring them down or hold
them accountable easily it's always a
battle but I do think there have been a
very some very significant changes as a
result of the reporting there hasn't
been a lot of legislation passed in fact
there's been none at least yet that has
restricted what the NSA can do but I've
never thought that the way to look the
place to look for restrictions on the
power of the US government would be the
US government itself because human
beings just generally don't walk around
thinking about ways to restrict their
own power
I think the much more significant
changes are the changes in consciousness
that people have not just about
surveillance but about privacy the role
of government their relationship to it
the dangers of exercising power in the
dark and the role of journalism as well
and I think there's all kinds of ways
that surveillance is now being curbed
from other governments acting in
coalition to impede us hegemony over the
Internet to technology companies like
Facebook and Yahoo and google knowing
that unless they make a real commitment
to protecting their users privacy
they're going to lose a generation of
users to other countries companies and
then most important of all is the
awareness of individuals about the need
to protect their own privacy by using
things like encryption and other tools
of anonymity and I think these things
are a really important form of change
and accountability that will come from
the reporting it's time also a factor
because I know you do mention this in
the book and in the issue there's a fear
of surveillance and there's a shock and
then over time you get used to the
cameras being on you and I know this
just as a photojournalist in the
beginning you put a camera on someone
and they're nervous they're worried
about their appearance and then after an
hour it's like oh it's not even there
anymore does that dilute the urgency in
any way I think there there is
definitely an extent to which you can
normalize almost every form of abusive
behavior on the part of the state you
can pretty much a customer population to
almost anything their studies at that
show that at the end of the stasi when
the wall and East Germany fell and even
once East Germans became integrated into
the West our until East into Germany
it's the road reunified Germany that
behaviorally it took a long time for
East Germans to change many population
under this repressive tyrannical
microscope of surveillance - one that
was free because they had become
acculturated to simply accept in the
world with those kinds of limitations
but I also think that there is an
instinctive Drive that human beings have
for for privacy for having a place where
we can go and think and communicate
and act without the judgmental eyes of
other people being cast upon us because
we understand reflexively how important
that is to be able to dissent and
explore who we are and so I don't ever
see a time when people will be satisfied
with having no privacy in the digital
age I do want to talk about just whether
the NSA blanket surveillance is now you
know is legal legally permissible under
any possible interpretation of the law
in your opinion yeah I mean I think you
know I think it's important to
understand we talked about what's legal
is the extent to which our institutions
that determine legality have been
completely co-opted either by the other
branches of government or just by the
kind of post 9/11 fear-mongering and
hysteria that has subsumed federal
judges as much as they have everybody
else if not more so take the Patriot Act
for example if you that the Patriot Act
section 215 of the Patriot Act is the
provision that the Justice Department
cited to convince the FISA Court to
allow the NSA to collect all telephone
records from Verizon and Sprint and
every other major carrier the metadata
of every person with whom every other
American is communicating that was the
legal provision that was signed it was
section 215 of the Patriot Act if you go
back and look at the debate that took
place over the Patriot Act and there was
a debate over the the Patriot Act even
in the wake of 9/11 there were lots of
people standing up and saying this is
really alarming this is going to vast
extremist surveillance power in the
government nobody thought neither the
proponents of the Patriot Act who wrote
it like Jim Sensenbrenner who were
devoted to extremist power in the wake
of 9/11 nor the critics of the Patriot
Act who were motivated to depict as
extremists of a picture of the
legislation as they could nobody
remotely dreamed that that Walken ever
be cited to justify mass indiscriminate
surveillance on Americans all it did was
lower this standard so that you no
longer needed probable cause but a much
lower level of proof of suspicion
reasonable suspicion to target somebody
for surveillance and yet a FISA Court
ended up accepting this rendition of the
Patriot Act in secret that nobody thinks
that it possibly permits and so that's
really become the problem is the law
almost is a
it's twisted and distorted by the very
institutions I'm supposed to safeguarded
to justify almost anything the
government wants to do it sound like a
very similar situation to how torture
and waterboarding was was permitted
right right I mean the law is you know
in its most idealized form it's this
consistent objective concrete
identifiable set of rules and principles
that constrict people's behavior but in
reality the laws like everything else is
an instrument that those who wield the
greatest power can use to maximize their
power and to shield themselves from
challenge and protection and you're
exactly right nobody thought
waterboarding and these other techniques
were anything but illegal criminal
torture in fact the US government has
prosecuted people for using them exactly
on that theory but legal memos got
written courts have if not accepted them
accepted the fact that their existence
justified the decisions and so they just
become legal by sort of Fiat power and
that's why although when I began writing
about politics as a journalist I focused
a lot on legal questions I almost never
focus on them now because they're really
not relevant to this struggle for power
or popular opinion I'd like to talk a
little bit about the intercept
can you explain just what is the
intercept first of all and what is it
going to provide what is it gonna
provide to the public that isn't already
out there in this diverse world of media
in which we live so it's a little
difficult to describe what the intercept
is because it's still very much a work
in progress what it is technically is a
digital magazine that was co-founded by
myself Jeremy Scahill and Laura Poitras
and it's funded by first look media
which is headed by pyramid er the the
founder of eBay the idea behind it when
we began was that there had there's been
fundamental flaws in American journalism
that we wanted to set out I wouldn't say
to rectify because that's too much of an
ambitious aspiration but to at least
start to work to produce other models
and I think you know the central flaw
that we the mother to central flaws I
think we wanted to rectify one was the
fact that most well-funded institutional
media outlets would be
for a variety of reasons far too close
to and deferential to those who wield
the greatest political and economic
power as opposed to adversarial to it
and therefore have kind of gutted the
purpose of journalism which is to serve
as a check on those who wield power not
as a kind of uncritical servant or
amplifier of their message and then the
second flaw that we want to talk defy
was the kind of lack of vibrancy and
independence and how journalists are
allowed to report and opine and talk
about the world there's kind of become
this very soul draining soulless voice
that journalists are expected to adopt
it's sort of one of contrived neutrality
or objectivity that prevents them from
really having any passion or spirit
behind their journalism and we really
wanted to reanimate the idea of what
journalism was supposed to be which is
not this kind of cloistered profession
that follows all these archaic unwritten
rules that really just kind of neuters
it but instead was was was about
crusading for some kind of outcome or
against a particular injustice and that
means letting journalists be free to
pursue their a voice and not trying to
modernize them or neuter them I followed
your debate with Bill Keller and I
thought that was terrific by the way
both you're both real and opposite sides
of that coin but what I didn't maybe
gather entirely from that this idea of
what's the future of journalism you know
is it is an objective old or not so old
as you pointed out but you know the this
sort of established standard of
objective news or some you know
intensely subjective and more
adversarial is there room for both
there's a couple of new media outlets
that are making really ambitious claims
about reinventing journalism in whatever
the image is that they want to do and we
tried really hard to avoid that we're
not trying to reinvent journalism like
we don't think we have the model of how
journalism should be practiced we have a
model of journalism that we think has
been woefully lacking and you know if
there are media outlets that
want to do different things I think you
know there's definitely other ways to do
journalism besides we do them that
contribute value but I do think that the
prevailing model is actually quite
destructive in part because it's
fraudulent this idea that the New York
Times or The Washington Post talks about
the world and reports on the world
without biases or subjectivity or
opinions as human beings I just think we
in we perceive the world through a
subjective prism we're not capable of
the kind of objectivity to which these
media outlets claim there they're there
they're capable of and I think it's much
more honest to simply be candid about
the subjective assumptions that you're
embracing rather than to pretend that
you're you're something that you're not
but more to the point I think that kind
of pseudo objective journalism renders
it it neuters it it means that if you
can't really ever be perceived as taking
a strong position because that's somehow
compromises your objectivity it means
that you basically are toothless that
you no longer have the ability to check
those who are in power or to call out
their lives when they're lying or to be
aggressive in in telling the truth and I
think that's a big part of why
journalism has been failing and is that
is that really at heart the promise of
new media today that it can engage in
different ways of looking at things and
with a multitude of different voices
yeah I think I mean diversity of voices
is probably the most important part of
how the Internet has affected journalism
because it really is true it's it's an
amazingly rapid and fundamental change
in how information and news gets
delivered to people I mean 10 years ago
if you wanted to have just 10 years ago
if you wanted to find a large platform
where you could reach large numbers of
people you pretty much have to go to
work for one of these large institutions
and subject yourself to all they're
really constrictive rules for how
journalism is supposed to be done now
you know you can just start a blog on
the internet if you offer something
unique you'll find a big readership and
you're free of all these constraints or
you didn't even need to start a blog I
mean if you look at how the Israeli war
on Gaza was perceived which i think was
much different around the world than
prior Israeli incursions into Gaza
we're perceived the primary reason that
happened is
because everybody in Gaza essentially
was a journalist because they all have
cell phones with video capabilities and
then internet access that they could
upload things to Twitter and it really
has democratized the number of people
and the kinds of voices who are shaping
how we perceive the world and I think
that's all for the good and it gives you
a leg up a little bit because when you
were struggling to get the very first
dispatches of the Snowden story out
right you had the option of saying well
if they keep delaying if they keep
postponing I can set up my own website
and publish it that way can you talk a
little bit about how that actually gave
you a little bit of an advantage you
wouldn't have otherwise had before you
would've been completely reliant on the
on the mainstream definitely I mean just
imagine pre-internet for example if you
want to talk to Daniel's Berg about the
challenges that he faced when he wanted
to disseminate the Pentagon Papers the
first challenge that he faced was simply
a logistical one of how do you make a
Xerox copy of 7,000 top-secret pages
without detection like you go into the
drugstore or library with the stack of
Dimes and you know start copying the
Pentagon Papers but then more so there
were very few media outlets capable of
publishing it and disseminating it in
any way that would make an impact I mean
there were a small handful of them and
most of them were afraid and had all
kinds of restrictions and the New York
Times funding undertook the fight but if
they hadn't he might have been prevented
from having that heard in any meaningful
way and the Internet has completely
obliterated that monopoly that these
small number of large corporations media
companies have on our discourse and
you're absolutely right I mean when you
know this is the first story that I
really did at the Guardian where I had
to work directly with their their
editors because my my arrangement with
every publication where I had written
both my own blog and so on prior to that
and the Guardian was that I just write
what I want to write I upload it
directly to the internet no editor
reviews that let alone changes it but
obviously with a story of this magnitude
with the legal liability and the
journalistic challenges I had to work
with the Guardian and I was a little bit
there was no basis of trust because we
hadn't worked together on on any kind of
a story and so any sign at all from them
that they weren't going to be as
aggressive as I wanted to be in
publishing this did made me make me
start considering other alternatives
the fact that I did have other
alternatives and they could have just
published it all on my own site and made
as big of an impact or at least
certainly close to it gave me a lot of
leverage to be able to negotiate with
them and reach an agreement about how
the reporting should be done yeah that
was that was an amazing part of the
story we're literally we're talking
about minutes before this self-imposed
deadline you gave the Guardian right
right I mean you know a big part of it
was we had just seen this twenty nine
year old kid who grew up with no you
know grew up in a totally ordinary way
with no background of power position or
prestige undertake this extraordinary
extraordinarily brave act knowing that
he was sacrificing his life to do it
and so I wanted to make sure that the
reporting that was done on the materials
he had furnished was done within the
same ethos of boldness and fearlessness
and courage and I was worried that the
Guardian institutionally would be
resistant to that and ultimately they
weren't that courage not only was
contagious and infused me and Laura and
and and the other people with whom we
were directly working with the Guardian
as well but I think a big part of it was
the fact that you know I need these big
institutions and they know that and so
they become much more flexible and what
they're going to do say the intercept
were to become very successful what is
to prevent it from sort of falling into
that trap and becoming the same old sort
of establishment the publication that
you criticize say the Washington Post
for being at many times you're going to
have to you get to break big stories and
to keep a lot of right you can have to
hire risk-averse lawyers right you're
going to have to have a hierarchy of
editors and people who take orders from
other people and who are responsible for
different parts of the operation this is
just part of is not just part of having
a news operation yeah I mean the danger
is definitely there but but because this
kind of journalistic ethos is not just
something that we kind of is on our
checklist of things we hope to achieve
but it's central to everything that all
of us you began the intercept believe in
at our core structuring our organization
to avoid those dangers has been the by
far the first and overarching priority
so when we went to hire lawyers we
purposely went and hired
lawyers who would be risk seeking and
not risk averse and that was one of the
kind of core mandates of what we were
doing was that unlike media outlets that
are suffering financially and therefore
tell their lawyers make sure to keep us
out of expensive litigation that we
can't afford with governments or large
corporations we've told our lawyers we
want to seek out litigation when
someone's threatening our journalistic
freedom to be able to litigate in
defense of it and fight for it that's
one of the advantages of being extremely
well-funded
or hierarchically and how we structure
ourselves we don't want to impose in
this top-down way editors who are now
the bosses of journalists who these
journalists have to kind of get around
or convince to allow them to publish the
journalists went and hire the editors
with whom they're working and they work
very collaboratively and there is no
kind of strict hierarchical or rigid
sequence where nothing can get published
unless one editor says yes you can
publish this and and so that danger does
exist but we're trying to construct
everything so that it's infused with
this spirit of fearless independent
journalism so that we don't become the
Washington Post interesting I mean
culture goes a long way institutional
culture right I mean sure and reason I
feel like this is a similar kind of
culture actually where there's a general
tone but where each one of us is given a
tremendous amount of leeway to shape
stories the way right there's writers at
that region who I think agree with each
other a lot but also disagree with each
other quite a lot and there's writers
who have very distinctive voices but
there seems to be this kind of spirit
that you want people who are sort of
idiosyncratic and independent and have
strong voices and and I do get an
important part of keeping journalism not
just relevant but interesting and sort
of the funding to the economic side of
journalism is really changing and what's
interesting is you're not following the
old models they're in a way following it
you right I mean if you look at the
Washington Post which you talk about a
lot in the book they're actually
following the intercept model now right
there a billionaire comes over and
starts and takes over the joint and
starts hiring
unusual different voices that are never
part of the mainstream before and giving
them a better platform than ever before
yeah I mean you know I I'm not I'm not
one who things that finding billionaires
is certainly not the only model the same
journalism and and it's not necessarily
a very desirable one because there are
dangers to having one person with huge
economic power being the primary of not
so low nor in funder of a news
organization the temptation to influence
it is always going to be very potent and
even if it's not overt it can be a
chilling kind of effect where the people
at these or institutions know what the
funder and owner want and believe and
kind of just subconsciously avoid doing
things that might alienate him and so
the only reason why we were willing to
do it is because we became very
convinced of the particular billionaire
who happens to be funding our news
organization a is really committed to
the idea of journalistic independence he
could have bought the Washington Post if
he had wanted to and purposely didn't
because he didn't want to kind of
inherit one of these legacy media
outlets he wanted to do something
different and be he's also extremely
well aware the minute he tried to
interfere in any remote way with what we
were doing would be the very minute that
all of us would leave and the whole
thing would just not exist anymore but
there are hazards to that model as well
but you know all of these models for
sustaining journalism and a meaningful
way are imperfect and you just have to
try and minimize the flaws and maximize
the value I'd like to go to the question
this question which I really think is
such a key aspect of your book and in
some ways it's the story of Snowden is
really just a springboard for I think
some larger philosophical issues that
you really get into about who's gets to
be considered an Insider in the
establishment who's an outsider I think
that that this dynamic is I I wouldn't
necessarily say universal because that's
probably too great of a claim but it's
it's extremely common across cultures
and and and eras the idea that
orthodoxies are maintained by imposing
punishment for those who defy them I
think it's always the case or most often
the case that there are that the path of
least resistance is to embrace and act
in accordance with societal convention
and there are generally punishments for
deviating from that convention and so a
big part of it is just simply that
normal human dynamic
people who wield power have an interest
in having the status quo or the
prevailing order maintained and one
important way of doing that is to ensure
that there are penalties for those who
challenge it and I do think one
important penalty that gets imposed on
those who challenge it is the idea of
societal scorn or shame that you'll be
depicted in the terms that you've
described as crazy or unstable or you
know I mean as I said you can find
Soviet and Chinese dissidents who were
put into mental hospitals rather than
prisons on the grounds that they were
crazy for challenging the prevailing
order scientists like Galileo and
Copernicus were and Socrates in
philosophy were regarded similarly and
so I think there's a very important
component of it there and I think one of
the reasons why journalists who are very
amply rewarded become such reliable
servants of powers because they do have
an interest in preserving the status quo
but this concept of craziness is is
remarkable there was actually a
fantastic article written in 2010 and
Newsweek by Connor fruit absorb the now
writer at Newsweek when I forget exactly
the context but either Rand Paul or Ron
Paul I believe it was Rand Paul had made
a few statements and got vilified for
being crazy and and content or the
craziest person in Washington and Connor
wrote an article saying you can think
some of those views are crazy and they
certainly don't have very much support
so they're probably by definition on the
fringe but it's important to remember
that even the most popular opinions are
the things that are done by those who
seem like they're the guardians of
convention can also be really crazy like
the idea of being able to target an
American citizen for execution by drone
without due process it's actually a
really radical and one could say crazy
idea and if it were being proposed by
some fringe ideologue rather than being
done by a popular American president it
would be regarded as just so
self-evidently crazy and this is a term
that gets applied I think to any
dissidents to any people who express
fringe views it's just a way of kind of
deal Ajith amaizing
views that challenge convention and
orthodoxy without having to do the work
to engage them and yet at the same time
you make the point that it's absolutely
crucial that journalists be Outsiders
well I'll give you an example we were
talking with this a little bit earlier
before we begin the discussion but you
know we're in Montreal right now last
night I was in Toronto and I gave a
speech to a audience of several hundred
people who were largely supportive and
sympathetic of the work that I had done
and yet there was a discussion as part
of this event where I was asked about a
recent attack that's being called a
terrorist attack in Canada
[Applause]
but this week's events are a grim
reminder the Canada is not immune to the
types of terrorist attacks we have seen
elsewhere around the world
and I made some points about the role
that Canada had played in potentially
provoking these kind of attacks the
causal relationship between Canadian
foreign policy on the one hand and the
desire of Muslims to bring violence to
Canada on the other and I can tell at me
the audience extremely uncomfortable
notwithstanding the fact that they were
there largely to support what I was
doing and probably agreed with me on
most things and I remember after I had
mentioned that I had intended to write
about it that day but didn't have time
but I was going to write about it for
sure the next day which was which is
today and someone afterwards a
journalist who works in Canada who I've
worked with came up to me and said you
know you should really think twice about
whether you want to write that because
you could tell how uncomfortable it made
even your supporters and it's probably
going to cause you a lot of grief if you
do it so you might want to think twice
about doing it and I said well that's
actually all the more reason to do it
right that's my role my role is not as a
journalist is not to give comfort I'm
not a therapist or a nurse or you know a
pastor I mean I think one of the most
crucial parts of journalism is to
constantly poke and prod at convention
and orthodoxy and she challenged
assumptions that people are just
implicitly accepting not just even if it
makes people uncomfortable but
especially that I think you need always
to have every kind of human belief being
challenged and scrutinized and CIAM and
put under a microscope and I think
that's an important part of what
journalism is about it is but I mean do
you romanticize that aspect of the
journalistic sort of viewpoint a little
bit I mean for example yes you've come
under fire from a lot of journalists and
people calling for your imprisonment in
some cases and all that but isn't that
just part of what you're actually
promoting which is adversarial
journalism that no some some people are
going to look at you and in a really
negative light right they're going to
ask you the same kind of hard questions
that you would ask of the NSA for
example absolutely you know what I think
that you know a journalist tend to be
really thin skinned I think sometimes
journalists especially in the Internet
age where where was is really the first
time that journalists had to be
confronted with criticism
you know ten years ago if you run a
column for the New York Times if you're
a marine down at Tom Friedman the only
criticisms you ever heard were people
who wrote letters to the editor and got
published and none of them ever cared at
all about that now you know everywhere
they go Tom Friedman and Maureen Dowd
here constant and you know sometimes the
criticism is vicious and it's vitriolic
and it's personal and unproductive and
whatever but I think that world where
people who have a platform and any kind
of influence over public discourse I'd
rather have those people and I include
myself in that subjected to excessive
criticism and attack then insufficient
criticism and attack okay I hope you
read that Matt Taibbi famous world is
flat yeah sure of course I mean that
must have gotten to him right I mean
there's no question I'm free but it's
well aware of that essay but you
document a very long list of
establishment journalists who have
called for your arrest in many cases and
some of them actually apologized to you
right like Andrew Ross Sorkin did David
Gregory has afterwards I would arrest
him and now I almost arrest Glenn
Greenwald who's the journalist who seems
to be out there on what he wants to help
him get to Ecuador put my foot in my
mouth and I'm sorry about this when I
veered into hyperbole and suggested that
he almost be arrested that was the quote
and I have to say it didn't come out
right and I misspoke I know they
apologized but do they ever explain what
prompted that accusation to say you
should go to prison I'm sorry I said
that like what prompts did they explain
what prompts that Andrew Ross Sorkin did
apologize um he apologized both on
Twitter and then on air and he I don't
recall exactly what he said but I think
the essence of it was that he had just
kind of gotten so caught up in the
emotions of watching this person that he
things had committed treason or serious
crimes Edward Snowden essentially get
away with it by by being able to remain
outside the grasp of the US and that to
the extent I had any kind of a role in
that he felt like I should have to pay a
price for that as well and even that you
know view although more mild in the view
that I should be imprisoned is itself
really questionable because you know he
is a journalist at the New York
times which is a history of defending
leakers and sources and actually going
to court all the way up to the Supreme
Court to win the right to publish huge
amounts of top-secret material when the
government was trying to suppress them
to do so and so the fact that there's
this prominent New York Times columnist
who views what Edward Snowden did not as
an act of courage or at the very least
enabling journalism but as an act of
treason and criminality
I think underscores how closely
identified these journalists now are
with those who wield power the
government looks at Edward Snowden
understandably as a criminal and as an
enemy and therefore these journalists
you see the world through the prism of
the government do as well so a lot of
the revelations that you came across
from from Snowden they have in many ways
proven to be more outrageous than even
the most sort of creative conspiracy
theorists could have ever imagined and I
you even write about how shocked you
were personally and I'm wondering did
that have an impact on how you know or
even whether you view our government as
a in general as a force for good did it
make you more skeptical about it
definitely I don't see how it can not do
that you know I've been writing about
the dangers of of state surveillance US
surveillance for a lot of years and have
been you know we've gotten little
snippets of the magnitude of the
surveillance just how unaccountable and
out-of-control it is but to see the
sheer breadth of it the fact that their
explicit institutional ambition is to
collect all communications on the
internet literally all is is something
that is is difficult to explain in terms
of how you react but it does feel like
you're confronted with this kind of
almost caricature of tyranny which is a
hard word to use when you're talking
about your own government because we're
so inculcated to think of tyranny is
something that happens elsewhere in bad
countries but to watch the US government
in its own documents not just trying
becoming very close to converting the
internet into a realm of unlimited
indiscriminate surveillance which is
another way of saying eliminating
privacy in the digital age is really
stunning but I think the more
or jarring part of it is how secretive
it all was so you watch your government
that claims to be a democracy and claims
to be accountable to its citizenry
through the ballot box engaging in this
indescribably consequential behavior and
purposely keeping not just the details
but the broad strokes of what they're
doing completely secret from the people
who are supposed to be deciding whether
or not they want their government to be
doing that I mean it's a real subversion
not just a privacy but of democracy
itself and ya know watch it in in in
action essentially and with the
definitive proof of what they're doing
definitely heightened my my skepticism
over the reliability of the US
government's claims the role they play
in the world and its motives as well
have you been surprised or disappointed
in any way with kind of the weak
reaction against the NSA by a lot of the
people on the Left it's been really I
mean I know I haven't been surprised in
part because there were so many other
policies that progressives or liberals
or Democrats whatever you want to
describe them as being pretended not
just to oppose but to vehemently
condemned and be offended by when it was
done when they were done by George Bush
and when Barack Obama was condemning
them and then they just stood by quietly
meekly acquiescing if not outright
endorsing Obama once he was in power
embracing these same theories and
sometimes even expanding them so this
kind of radical grotesque form of
progressive hypocrisy was something that
I had become extremely accustomed to had
written about and had just accepted as a
fact of life at the same time the
reaction to the NSA reporting on the
conservative side was was actually quite
mixed it is true there were a lot of
conservatives who were consistent
meaning they defended eavesdropping in
the bush regime and they defended it
when done under obama and were hostile
the reporting but a huge amount of the
support for edward snowden in the
reporting that we were doing came from
the right as well as the left and in
part a lot of that was just a separate
critical as
the hypocrisy on the left because a lot
of those conservatives were perfectly
fine with the NSA scandal under George
Bush and suddenly got worried about
individual privacy where the Democrat
was in control but a lot of it was this
kind of small government Pro individual
privacy strain on the right that was
offended by the idea of this level of
government spying and it was really
interesting because there it didn't
break down at all along partisan or
ideological lines in fact if you look at
the at first NSA vote to defund the bulk
metadata collection program the two
sponsors were John Conyers and Justin
Amash you can't find more despread
members of Congress and those doing the
the people that lined up behind them to
do that were across the range of for the
political spectrum ultimately the big
break down was more along demographic
lines where young people attempted to
support Snowden and to be really
offended and alarmed by this kind of
surveillance while older people were
more tolerant of it but the the behavior
of the Democrats was completely
predictable they pretended to be
hideously bothered by a much smaller
scale amount of eavesdropping revealed
under George Bush and then completely
supportive of what was done under
President Obama maybe you can help me
clarify just want to quote you to you
for a second I think the only means of
true political change will come from
people working outside of that two-party
electoral system to undermine it and to
subvert it and to weaken it and to
destroy it not to try to work within it
to change it and I'm curious how far you
take this because I know in other
context you've actually written
endorsing certain candidates right
certain candidates who are either
against NSA spying or in some cases
against the war on drugs even right so
you know I don't think it's an absolute
proposition that no value can ever come
from working within the political system
there is value that I had in my own work
from having Russ Feingold on the Senate
because he could call hearings on things
that nobody else would call hearings on
that could force some transparency there
are people who introduce debates that
nobody else would introduce like when
Jim Webb introduced the idea of prison
reform and drug policy reform a really
courageous thing to do that very few
other members of Congress would have
done so it isn't that I don't think
there's any value from working within
the political process and you're right
I've endorsed candidates I raise money
for
I've done it as recently as the last
election cycle but what I'm really you
know critiquing there is is the fact
that the two primary parties despite all
these claims of a lack of bipartisanship
and these claims that they can't get
along are in fact in accord on far more
than they disagree on and what they're
in accord on isn't political or
ideological perspectives it's the fact
that they serve the interests of those
who control and fund the political
system and the same prevailing permanent
factions in Washington end up reigning
supreme regardless of whether Democrats
or Republicans win elections sometimes
they exercise the power in the private
sector and other times they exercise in
the public sector which have become
almost merged but the same interests end
up being served and so you can spend all
your time and energy working to affect
the outcome of political elections or
the Democrats the Republicans going to
get empowered but ultimately most of the
weighty questions don't really end up
being changed some do but most don't
depending on on that process as this
year is a winner of the Lanny Freelander
prize can you tell us a little bit about
what that winning that prize means to
you
you know I'm thrilled when the award for
a couple reasons one is almost instantly
from the beginning of the time that I
started writing about politics it was
clear to me that there are people on the
opposite side of the political spectrum
who are encouraged to view each other as
implacable enemies who actually have far
more in common with one another than
they do often with the people who they
think they're on the same side as and so
having this kind of coalition of people
it sort of began being conceived as a
coalition of liberals and libertarians
but I think my views on that have become
more complicated about what this
coalition is and who's involved in it I
try really hard never to be pigeonhole
Bowl ideologically or otherwise because
I want to make sure that I can work with
people who with whom I'm in agreement on
a whole wider range of issues and I've
done things in the past with reason and
have had a lot of agreement with the the
policies and editorial positions of
reason so I'm thrilled to get
recognition for that reason but also I
think that they're the
the much more relevant split politically
is no longer left versus right or
Democrat versus Republican but has
really become insider versus outsider
and again you saw this I think most
prominently in the last year with that
NSA vote I mentioned earlier where the
people who saved the NSA program a bulk
book medical data communication was the
White House Nancy Pelosi and John Bainer
this kind of unholy trinity of
establishment insiders who whipped all
their sort of establishment members of
Congress in defense of the NSA and you
had the kind of Tea Party Outsiders with
the outsiders on the left joining
together to try and defund it and this
coalition has actually become more
apparent in lots of different areas
including drug policy and penal reform
and intervention and war questions and
so any kind of award that's based on
encouraging or trying to recognize
people who are trying to work outside of
these establishment institutions and
work against them is one that I'm really
happy to receive your specific areas of
overlap do you think between the left
and the libertarian coalition's here
absolutely I mean the question of of
intervention and war has become I think
a huge hugely divisive issue on the
right where there are all kinds of
conservatives whether it be Ted Cruz or
Rand Paul who are questioning the kind
of Reaganesque you know we have two more
John McCain Pro intervention posture and
in almost every single case and often
find common ground on the left but even
on economic questions you know when it
came time to try and audit the Fed a
longtime cause of Ron Paul he found a
really important ally and Alan Grayson
and it was only because they were able
to then tap until liberals and
libertarians were they able to get a
bill passed and the whole question of I
mean even if you look at the two kind of
agitation movements of the last five
years which was Occupy Wall Street and
the Tea Party movement perceived as
polar opposites they were both actually
born out of an anger over the bailout
and so I think objections to crony
capitalism and the kind of inherent
corruption of how the public and private
sectors are interacting are also
commonality
among the left and the right and those
are some extremely significant issues I
mean those and then you add to that
social issues as well whether it be
choice or marriage equality where you
find advocates of those positions on
both the right and the left as well so I
think there's a lot more common ground
than people typically recognize Glenn
Greenwald it has been a pleasure to
speak with you thank you for joining us
I'm Todd crane in for Reason TV
[Music]